hey we're back hi
we're back this is carly's brand new
apartment
i've never been in here so not only am i
going to give you guys a little tour i'm
also
going to show jerry look out world
spencely is back
on the show i have a roommate named
harper and this is our home together
life's too short to hold a grudge and
yet you won't forgive me for that
leggings incident
you didn't tell me you could see my
whole butt through them i thought that's
why you bought them
the refrigerator is very cute it's like
kind of small it doesn't hold a lot
love the look though very vintagey look
there's an array of
how are you not gassy all the time this
is
goat milk this whole kitchen is so cute
the little stove
help yourself to a mimosa pancakes are
on the way
we have like a balcony out there the sun
is just touching the horizon
and as it sinks further the bright hot
gold
gently fades to a warm soothing thing
now help me pee i just love all this
stuff yes your decorations are great i
love the bar cart
i love that lamp i'm completely in tune
with my surroundings
did you rearrange the furniture our
space is so much smaller than your
apartment all righty you know money's
not everything
don't leave martini yes please you can
really taste the gold
and that's pretty much a little tour of
harper and carly's apartment thank you
for giving me the tour i appreciate it